Il est temps d'aller chasser le Pokémon
Pokémon Go
Les amis Pokémon Go est sorti
Même pas en France d'ailleurs, il est sorti qu'en Australie et aux US
Et c'est pourtant déjà un gros buzz en France
On a pu se procurer l'application, et aujourd'hui on va chasser le Pokémon dans les rues de Paris! J'ai plus d'air
Du Salamèche, du Bulbizarre, du Carapuceau
Comme nous, puceau
On est tous un peu puceaux du coup cette année
Hein, parce qu'on va tous chasser le pokémon on va pas se mentir
Allez, suivez-moi, suivez le guide, on y va
Donc là juste à droite, ces carrés bleus
sont en fait des Pokéstop
Et si je vais à proximité
je peux faire tourner la pièce
et je gagnerai par exemple des Pokéball
Ou des trucs intéréssants bon là il y a que de la merde une baie qu'est ce que je m'en bas les couilles
Bon là il y a un deuxième Pokéstop qui est collé au premier Pokéstop
Ça c'est bien tu sais ce que ça veut dire ça ?
Carapuce il est pas loin
Donc là je tourne la pièce
Et vu que c'est pas sorti en France et qu'il y a une connexion de merde
Et bah ça tourne dans le vide
*Sourire forcé*
Apparemment, il y a un Miaouss qui est pas très loin
Et un Ptitard et des Ratatats mais ça on s'en bat les couilles
C'est des petits rats, de toute façon régulièrement ils se bouffent de la mort aux rats
Ils crèvent avant qu'on ne les capturent, c'est rarement des cons
Il pleut *renifle* tu sais ce que ça sent cette pluie ?
Tu veux que je te dise... *galère avec son fusil en plastique*
Tu veux que je te dise ce que ça sent cette pluie ? *renifle son fusil* ça sent le Carapuce
Nan nan nan ! Tortank...
Ça sent Tortank.
Là aujourd'hui c'est un peu la crise
C'est le 14 juillet, les Pokémons hier
ils ont fait la fête donc ils sont encore dans leur lit
Donc se qu'on va faire là, c'est que je vais utiliser une baie vous voyez
Euh une baie n'importe quoi. Je vais utiliser un encens.
Et un encens c'est simple, ça va me permettre finalement
d'avoir des Pokémons plus souvent, voilà
Par exemple, Carapuceau on a vraiment envie qu'il
termine dans notre inventaire donc on va tout faire... Oh ! *s'arrête surpris*
Y'a un Aspicot
Y'a un Aspicot, y'a un Aspicot. Il est là, il est là, il est là
Chut. Écarte-toi attention, attention madame c'est dangereux
Écartez-vous *lance la Pokéball*
C'est bon !
Attention, est-ce qu'on l'a capturé ?  *réussite*
Allez on a eu l'Aspicot !
Highfive ? *tend sa main à une passante et se fait ignorer*
*énorme vent*
Ça c'est... ça, ça montre bien la rivalité entre
chasseurs. C'est à dire que c'est un petit peu chacun sa gueule quoi
Tout le monde veut ses Pokémons enfin...
Wouah attention ! Avance pas, y'a juste
là-bas un Rattata
Lui il a évité la mort aux rats le con
Bah il va finir dans notre Pokéball et dire qu'il aurait préféré la mort aux rats
*rigole*
Ça a buggé. *interromps une passante* Excusez-moi ? -Oui ? -Vous auriez vu
un Rattata pas loin ? -Qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est un
petit rat, qu'on met dans notre Pokéball
-Je vois pas. Nan ? Vous êtes pas une dresseuse ?
Ah pardon, c'est une Pokéinfirmière putain
Par contre là il commence à pleuvoir sévère
Nan mais là il pleut sévère -Nan il pleut sec ouais
Nan bah nan. Alors attention il y a un
Nosferapti juste là ! Oh le con il dérange
les mecs du chantier quoi, putain *jette une Pokéball*
Ah j'ai raté la Pokéball
*réessaye* Ouais !
J'ai mon Nosferapti !
*montre à un passant* -Bien joué. Merci beaucoup
Y'a un Miaouss ! Il est à un pas. Attention y'a un Miaouss là madame
On va pouvoir aller le chasser et ce qui est bien, c'est que
j'ai déjà son évolution donc je m'en bas les couilles des Miaouss, allez *repart*
Donc là ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va marcher 4 kilomètres et demi
Et qu'au bout d'un moment j'ai des œufs qui vont éclorent
Et ensuite on pourra avoir un œuf 10 kilomètres
Ça veut dire que dedans y'aura un Pokémon
de type, de type légendaire voilà. Un gros Pokémon
tu vois. Un Pokédur. Attend ! Attend ! Bouge pas
Bouge pas, bouge pas, bouge pas, bouge pas, y'a un
Chenipan, y'a un Chenipan
Il est juste là *jette une Pokéball*
Oui !
Oui ! Allez rentre dans la Pokéball !
Rentre dans la Pokéball ! *réussite*
Voilà. Ça j'en ai déjà l'habitude
J'en prends tout les jours des Chenipans. Tu sais ce qu'on va faire ?
Tu veux que je t'expliques ? Tu veux que je t'ex... Bah je t'expliquerai pas
On va aller là-bas, y'a une arène
Donc dans Pokémon Go en faite y'a 3 équipes et t'en rejoins
une level 5, y'a les rouges
les jaunes et les... attention. Là c'est un piaf
Attends y'a un Piafabec
*cherche avec son téléphone*
*se tourne vers le cameraman* Attends bouge pas !
Bouge pas il est sur ton sac
Ne bouge surtout pas *jette la Pokéball* Ne bouge pas
C'est bon je l'ai eu. Piafabec mon gars
Tu sais qui c'est Piafabec ? C'est le Pokémon que personne ne veut
Bah il était sur ton sac tiens *rigole* Lui il voulait de toi *re-rigole*
Level 5 dans Pokémon Go tu rejoins
l'une des 3 équipes, la bleue,
la jaune ou la rouge. Moi j'ai rejoins la bleue
Là-bas y'a une arène qui a été prise par les rouges
Moi ce que je vous propose, c'est qu'on aille violer ces
putains de Pokémon rouges et quand je dis violer...
-Tu parles pas de la couleur ? Je parle pas de la couleur
Toi tu veux que je te file un Ronflex c'est ça ?
Attention attention attention attention. C'est quoi c'est un piaf ça ?
C'est un Roucool mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en bat les couilles d'un Roucool
Il est là il devant nous *jette une Pokéball mais échoue*
Ok *retente mais re-échoue*
Ok. Ah voilà *réussite*
Allez, c'est bon. Donc là l'arène
Tu vois ce jardin ? Ça c'est l'arène ça
Donc y'a les rouges, y'a 3 Pokémons qui la protègent
Y'a un petit Rattatac level 266
Un Roucarnage level 448
Et un Magmar (level) 682
Donc les mecs ils se croient chauds, ils se disent: Ça y est on
est les rouges, rouge c'est la couleur du feu,
on est forts; Bah on va leur montrer ce que valent les bleus
Et je parle pas de l'équipe de France, ça on a vu ce qu'ils valaient à l'Euro
et c'était grandiose. Ok on y est
Je vais lancer le combat. Je vais mettre
Persian, je vais mettre Insécateur
Je vais mettre mon Flagadoss
C'est parti ! On est en pleine baston
On va se faire le Rattatac. Hop hop hop
hop hop ! Allez Rattatac
il est mort, suivant ! Hop hop hop
Et là on va lancer la méga attaque
C'est Dracochoc, je vais pas
te mentir le Roucarnage, il a fait aucun carnage
Et là Magmar on va pouvoir lui faire la
grosse compétence de Ronflex qui inflige énormément
de dégâts voilà. Ça lui a retiré
que dalle. Ah si voilà ! Sa vie vient de chuter
Effectivement, et l'arène a chuté avec
Là l'arène elle est vierge, j'appuie dessus
Hop, Ronflex vas-y
Ça me rapportera des points tous les jours. Tu gagnes
des poussières et des pièces pour chaque Pokémon que t'as dans des arènes
tous les jours donc plus t'as d'arènes, plus t'as de tune
plus t'as de meilleurs Pokémon, plus t'es le meilleur dresseur
Là on va aller se faire une autre arène
Oh attend c'est quoi ça ? Un Li(poutou)... c'est les mêmes !
Les mêmes mecs qui avaient une arène là-bas
Donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va aller se la prendre
Donc l'arène c'est quoi ? C'est l'école
Sainte-Marie
*accroche son câble pour enregistrer à un poteau* *rires*
*rires* Donc là ça a dû corrompre
la capture c'est ça qui est bien *rires*
Du coup on est baisé *rigole*
Ok on est arrivé devant l'arène, elle ressemble à ça
À l'une des ces fenêtres, y'a probablement Lippoutou qui nous regarde
et qui se chie dessus. On arrive ! Cette arène est trop
loin *soupire* Bon alors quand c'est comme ça
vous sonnez *appuie sur la sonnette* et
vous leur expliquez la situation. -Oui monsieur c'est pour quoi ?
Oui bonjour madame, je viens pour combattre
le Lippoutou qui garde les lieux s'il vous plaît
-Euh l'école elle est fermée aujourd'hui monsieur
D'accord comment on peut faire du coup ? Faut que je revienne demain ?
-Je sais pas quoi vous dire en fait... -D'accord, j'aimerais quand même
que vous dites à votre Lippoutou
d'arrêter de me faire des doigts depuis la fenêtre parce que c'est pas très sympa
Parce que quand il va se prendre mon Lokhlass dans son cul !
Il fera moins le malin ton Lippoutou
*pointe le fusil sur la sonnette*  Et merde !
J'aurai ta mort !
Là ! Là attends
Y'a mon petit poulain, y'a mon petit poulain qui va naître
après 5 kilomètres. Attention j'aimerais trop un truc fou
Genre un Salamèche un Carapuce
Un truc incroyable *un Nidoran♀ sort de l'œuf*
Un Nidoran... C'est beau...
Tu sais pourquoi je souris ?
Parce que quand je suis né c'était un petit peu pareil quoi
Mes parents m'ont vus sortir de l'œuf comme ça et..
Ils étaient déçus
Tu sais ce que je fais quand je vais pas bien ?
Je me branle mais pas que
Je prends aussi des arènes
Et là y'a la team Or qui est pas loin !
*simule des tirs
Hein ?
Donc là y'a Scarabrute, Hypnomade et Roucarnage
Je vais prendre Insécateur, je vais prendre Persian avec Flagadoss
On va défoncer les jaunes mon pote
C'est parti !
Là y'a un petit Scarabrute
Alors là, j'ai Roucarnage, là ça être la fête, je vais envoyer que des sorts qui font très très mal
Hop hop hop
Ok mon Roucarnage s'en ai fait 2 à lui tout seul
Puis le petit dernier on va se le faire avec Scarabrute
*très concentré*
D'accord mon Scarabrute pue la merde
On va prendre Persian
*toujours concentré et a réussi à gagner*
Et ouais les gars je vous ai défoncé
On a pris l'arène, elle est à nous
Oh mon dieu Ptitard n'est plus qu'à 2 pas, Ptitard il est qu'à 2 pas
Il doit être par là, il doit être par là
Je l'ai ! Je l'ai ! Je l'ai !
Il était là, il était là il était en train de faire sa pause clope le con
Sur les marches ! *jette une Pokéball*
Alors est-ce qu'on l'a ?
*réussite*
C'est capturé
Bon bah du coup on va pouvoir...
On va se poser à la maison
On va boire le thé puis on va faire connaissance avec les Pokémons qu'on a capturé
De toute façon on n'a plus de batterie donc on va devoir rentrer, c'est juste là à droite
-Ah bah tiens pas mal -C'est juste ici à droite -Ministère de l'intérieur
Ministère de l'intérieur *rigole* -Avec un fusil
-C'est interdit de filmer monsieur
Ah pardon, on passe juste par là, on voulait pas du tout filmer ici
-Bonjour messieurs -Bonjour -Bonjour -Je pourrais savoir pourquoi vous prenez des photos dans le coin, comme ça ?
En fait il me filme en train jouer à Pokémon Go
C'est un jeu qui se fait dans la rue
En fait y'a des Pokémons dans les rues
Nan c'est pas un blaque je vous assure
-Bah on va juste faire un contrôle quand même